pause dans la polémique sur le fichier
sida des militaires le ministre de la
défense en effet via d'abroger l'arrêté
de son service de santé qui autorisait
le recueil des nos deux porteurs du
virus
explication des militaires il nous faut
ces informations lorsque nos soldats aux
besoins de donner leur sang sur les
théâtres d'opérations l'arrêté avait été
publiée au journal officiel du 19
février dans une rédaction ambiguë
cebu disait-il la gestion des patients
et la recherche de facteurs de risque
dans la population suivi ce qui revenait
à la constitution d'un fichier des
séropositifs les informations étaient
destinés à l'hôpital militaire laveran à
marseille
elle visait semble-t-il une centaine de
personnes le fichier déclare le
ministère de la défense a été mis en
place avec l'autorisation de la cnil la
commission nationale informatique et
libertés la cnil vient de préciser les
conditions dans lesquelles elle a donné
son accord pour l'accès aux fichiers
son accès est strictement réservée au
seul personnel médical du service
en aucun cas il n'est prévu de
transmission d'informations à
l'extérieur notamment marché militaire
c'est un usage strictement médical quai
réservé cette application informatique
le journal l'humanité ce matin avait
rendu public les protestations de trois
associations de lutte contre le sida
ces associations dénoncent l absence
d'anonymat de ce fichier en
contradiction totale avec les consignes
du gouvernement
nous contestons le fait que nous n'avons
pas besoin de données nominatives
pour étudier des souches virales et pour
étudier les risques de transmission dans
des populations donner c'est de la
sociologie c'est la virologie et on n'a
pas besoin de savoir le nom et les dates
de naissance d'une personne pour cela
satisfaction ce soir des associations
une surveillance médicale du sida est
possible déclare pelle dans le respect
des libertés individuelles